i would say that many women around the
age of i would say between 28 and 32
have a career family crisis that they
have to deal with and i think that's
partly because of the foreshortened time
frame that women have to contend with
like women have to get the major pieces
of their life put together faster than
men which is also part
i can't hear you
my life's not together yet
and i'm right there knocking on 28.
don't i don't want to hear it no
she has to have her career and family in
order
pretty much by the time she's 35
because otherwise the options start to
run out and so that puts a tremendous
amount of stress on women especially at
the end of their 20s i think i take
issue with the idea
that's a fact that's a it's a fact
he's spitting facts because
um 28 is right around the corner for me
and i'm like
at this point i want to email you
in the marriage i have mostly male
viewers if there's any cute guys in
london she's looking for money that's
the money gotta have money in a career
now
no he's it's it's not like a comfortable
truth but it's real right yeah it sucks
i'm like dang like why can't we be like
lenient with our lives kind of well
because a guy can have a kid at 50. yeah
us it's like if you hit 40 you're
pushing your love yeah
what i wonder why that is and that's
going to be a tangent but i just i've
always wondered like how come
our our reproductive system
like slows down or like just gets worse
as we get older
and the males they swimmers swim 24 7.
it's just biology it's just like life
isn't fair yeah
ah